[Musique]
alger le 24 octobre 1954
on
un dimanche comme les autres pour la
foule qui profitent de repos
hebdomadaire mais c'est un grand jour
pour ces six hommes qui posent ensemble
devant l'histoire et l'objectif d'un
petit photographe de bab el oued
aussitôt après il se disperse aux quatre
coins d'algérie chacun remporté une
épreuve de la photo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on se met plus tard une série
d'attentats perpétrés simultanément à
travers tout le territoire ce coup là
nuit de la toussaint la guerre d'algérie
vient de commencer
retrouvez les en algérie ou en plusieurs
endroits du territoire une série
d'attentats ont été commis dans la nuit
qui est passé d'un la toussaint
on parle de fellaghas et de complot
organisé par certaines ligue musulmane
mais l'algérie ne se prêtera pas au rôle
souhaité par les agitateurs on peut
croire que le calme sera vite rétabli
[Musique]
c'était il ya quarante ans le 1er
novembre 1954 la guerre d'algérie
commencer ce soir les brûlures de
l'histoire raconte qu'un surrection de
la toussaint 54 les causes lointaines
les préparatifs se crée le rôle des
hommes les archives filmées sont rares à
l'époque les clandestins ne convoquait
pas les caméras nous avons donc eu
recours aux témoignages difficile à
obtenir du côté algérien en raison de la
situation actuelle dans ce pays du côté
français trois hommes directement mêlé
aux événements apporte ce soir leur part
de vérité pierre nicolaï directeur de
cabinet de françois mitterrand mise
l'intérieur jean deleplanque sous-préfet
de batna au coeur de l'insurrection des
aurès jean vaujour directeur de la
sûreté l'homme de tous les secrets enfin
tout au long cette émission yves
courrière historiens l'auteur de
l'histoire de la guerre d'algérie
apportera réflexion et analyse il courir
est ce que vous avez un souvenir vous
personnel du 1er novembre 54
non absolument pas 1954 j'ai pas encore
commencé à être journaliste j'y pense
j'ai 19 ans et ce samedi rien n'est pas
de réaction particulière donc en
définitive votre question elle montre
bien tout ce problème de la première
partie de la guerre c'est que au fond
l'algérie on sait à peine ou sait et
tout le monde s'en fout alors comment et
quand vous est venue votre passion
finalement 2
de la guerre d'algérie vous êtes vous
avez été journaliste sol terrain vous
avez couvert la guerre d'algérie oui
j'ai été journaliste et puis j'ai été
militaire aussi j'étais très très marqué
par cette guerre d'une part par les
fonctions que j avais rempli et d'autre
part parce que j'avais beaucoup d'amis
musulmans que toute ma belle famille
était pieds noirs et que j'étais pris
entre les deux et je me suis rendu
compte et que j'ai souffert si vous
voulez à l'intérieur de moi même deux
qualités cette guerre d'algérie et vu
mon âge la guerre d'algérie avait été
pour moi jeune grand reporter ce qui
avait été la guerre d'indochine pour mes
aînés ou là la deuxième guerre mondiale
la résistance
où la guerre d'espagne pour les aînés
pour entreprendre cette histoire vous
avez mené une longue enquête à l'époque
c'était presque à chaud c'était pas
longtemps après la fin de la guerre
qu'est ce qu'il y avait comme comme
source pour un quelqu'un qui voulait
entreprendre cette histoire c'est à dire
qu'il fallait vraiment travailler en
journaliste j'ai fait là le plus non
grand portage est le plus poussé de
toute ma vie il a fallu retrouver les
gens parce que bien sûr il n'était pas
question d'avoir les archives françaises
puisque la fameuse loi des 50 ans qui me
l'interdisait et que d'autre part il il
a fallu retrouver les gens vous avez
écrit une histoire en quatre volumes ce
qui nous concerne particulièrement
aujourd'hui bien sûr c'est le premier
volume vous l'avais appelé des fils de
la toussaint pour écrire ce volume nous
a menés pour vous est au creux tout pour
retrouver les protagonistes des deux
côtés et un peu c'est un peu ce qu'on va
faire aujourd'hui en images puisqu'on va
sur vos traces essayer de voir comment
comment a débuté cette guerre mais je
crois que pour comprendre ce qui se
passe en 1954 il faut remonter au moins
en 1945 c'est qu'on fait maintenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
8 mai 1945 dans le défilé de la victoire
sur les champs-elysées l'armée d'afrique
est à l'honneur les milliers de nord
africains sont tombés sur les champs de
bataille de monte cassino de strasbourg
et d'ailleurs pour la libération de la
game ce sont des héros bardés de
médailles qu'on acclame à paris rabat
tunis où alger des héros qui retrouve
chez eux l'insupportable égalité
ce même 8 mai à sétif de jeunes
nationalistes veulent profiter du défilé
pour affirmer leurs revendications le
drapeau vert et blanc fait son
apparition des pancartes sont brandies
au policier perd son sang froid des
coups de feu éclatent un jeune arabe
c'est faux aussitôt c'est l'émeute
en quelques jours les dizaines
d'européens sont agressés utile est
assassiné
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout de suite les européens s'organisent
en milices et se livrent à des
représailles travel l'armée sous les
ordres du général duval mène une
répression terrible impitoyable on parle
officiellement de 15 cents victimes le
bilan réel est beaucoup plus long
récemment dit que la guerre d'algérie
avait commencé à ces types parce que
c'est une vérité donc je crois vraiment
qu elle a commencé ce jour là là c'est
vraiment spontané c'est la haine qui va
qu'il va éclater d'un coup ça sera plus
rien à voir avec ces grandes
manifestations dans l'est algérien
qui tiendront lieu
en 1955 au 20 août alors là où ça aura
été vraiment quelque chose ait un
massacre préparer là non combien
d'européens de français européens qui
sont massacrés de recycler quelques
jours alors là on peut dire que dans ces
deux jours autour de 8 et 9 mai il y as
je reprends les chiffres exacts de la
commission denquête il y à 104 européens
qui ont été tuées et il faut bien dire
les choses comme elles sont c'est que
quand
il y à ces morts et bien donnant des
détails qui sont qui sont épouvantables
mais et femmes sont violées on retrouve
même une pauvre femme de 84 ans qui a
été violée les hommes quand ils sont
tués c'est le ventre ouvert les parties
génitales dans la bouche je veux dire
que quand les militaires français ou les
gendarmes découvrent des spectacles
pareil qu'est-ce qui se passe bon c'est
une bouffée d'adrénaline
épouvantable après les massacres via la
répression à l'orgue à la répression et
la répression va être vraiment imbéciles
aveugle et là on va on va tuer pour tuer
depuis 45 et une controverse énorme sur
les chiffres de cette répression alors
aujourd'hui est ce qu'on peut dire que
ça les chiffres se balade entre 800 et
45000 donc je pense que comme la france
a fait à l'époque une commission
denquête on en pense qu'on en veut mais
il y a quand même les chiffres les plus
ils ont les plus minorés alors ces
chiffres voilà que voilà ce qu'ils sont
c'est la commission denquête elle a été
faite par un général qui est un général
de gendarmerie qui s'appelle tubert qui
est un homme plutôt libérale m'enfin
c'est pas non plus un enfant de coeur et
lui qu'est ce qu'il donne il donne ses
104 européen tué 5 à 6 ans indigènes
tués par l'armée dit le rapport cinq à
sept cents indigènes tués par les colons
parce que là il ya eu cette répression
aveugle il ya des colons qui dans le
bled se sont sont déjà armé ou se sont
armées royales exactement ces milices et
là on va tuer complètement aveuglément
pétales total bon qu'est ce que ça fait
un gros millier mais en définitive le
général tubert ça c'est ce qu'il a écrit
et puis dans les conversations dit non
ça a été beaucoup plus terrible que ça
et il estime à peu près la répression à
15000 morts quinze 15 mille morts
algériens alors bien sûr le fln plus
tard se servira de ces massacres de
sétif et on dira il ya eu 45 morts il ya
eu 55 mille morts il ya eu soixante
mille morts le du côté algérien on s'en
tiendra on reviendra au chiffre de 45
mille morts quinze mille c'est un
chiffre qui est
à peu près sûr heureusement et mais c
est exactement mais il ya une chose qui
est à dire qui est importante c'est que
à partir et c'est là où on peut dire que
la guerre d'algérie elle commence à
sétif c'est qu'à partir de sétif il ya
un fossé qui commence à se creuser entre
la population européenne dans la région
a uniquement dans la région entre la
population européenne et la population
musulmane il ya un mot moi qui me qui me
frappe c'est c'est un mot de ce grand
écrivain kateb yacine il dit
c'est à sétif il avait 16 ans cette
populace c'est à sétif que se cimente à
mon nationalisme et je pense que ce
nationalisme ya beaucoup beaucoup
d'algériens qui le verront naître tout
comme kateb yacine tout de suite à tous
les partis étaient d'accord et ce
qu'elle peut me tester les réactions en
france sur ce massacre on en a très très
peu parlé et ça c'est le problème
éternel de la france en tout cas dans
ses débuts de la guerre d'algérie comme
je vous le disais un peu trivialement en
commençant cette émission en france pour
monde s'en fout
[Musique]
je vous ai donné la paix pour dix ans
avait prédit le général duval il n'a
fait qu'accélérer la prise de conscience
nationaliste qui s'exprime dans trois
courants distincts le mouvement des
oulémas les docteurs de la loi coranique
fédérer depuis 1931 par le cheikh ben
badis les oulémas partisans d'un retour
valeur morale de l'islam étendent leur
influence par l'ouverture d'écoles
coraniques il contribue fortement à
donner au nationalisme algérien ses
racines culturelles
messali hadj le prophète barbu et
charismatique et la figure dominante du
nationalisme révolutionnaire entre exil
et prison dirige le ppa parti populaire
algérien créé en 1937 dissous en 39 mais
qui continue une existence clandestine
[Musique]
ferhat abbas enfin un modéré pétri de
culture française qui a longtemps cru à
l'assimilation avant de réclamer en 1943
dans son manifeste du peuple algérien un
état autonome associé à la france
ferhat abbas arrêté au moment des
émeutes de sétif libéré un an plus tard
créa parti lui dma qui montre sa
représentativité aux élections à la
constituante déjouer 1,46
[Applaudissements]
messali en novembre de la même année 46
de retour d'exil créé à son tour à parti
légal le mtld mouvement pour le triomphe
des libertés démocratiques
ils rentrent en 33 % des sièges aux
élections municipales de 47
ce succès est frais car entre temps à
paris la quatrième république enfin
installé dans sa constitution a voté un
statut pour l'algérie
ce statut qui comporte des mesures
libérales maintient le découpage en
trois départements sous la houlette d'un
gouverneur général
[Musique]
on prévoit la création d'une assemblée
algérienne formé par deux collèges de 60
mans
le premier collège représente les huit
cent soixante mille français le second
les 8 millions de musulmans les
inégalités demeurent et c'est un projet
qui inquiète étonnant de l'immobilisme
[Musique]
le statut doit être ratifié à la
majorité des deux tiers par l'assemblée
algérienne
pour élire la première assemblée
algérienne l'algérie tout entière a voté
2 millions d'électeurs sont allés aux
urnes les premiers citoyens français et
notables musulmans votant pour le
premier collège où les candidats unis
par l'idéal républicain les français
sont arrivés en tête
les autres musulmans a beau temps pour
le second collège où les partisans de
messali et de ferhat abbas ont essuyé un
échec premiers résultats la raison
triomphe en algérie et l'union française
s'organise
[Musique]
les adversaires du statut donc de
l'évolution en gagner mais il a fallu
bourrer les urnes le nom de gouverneur
général naegelen restera associé à la
fraude électorale les mêmes
tripatouillage se répéteront aux
élections de 1951 le statut de 47 gauthé
par l'assemblée nationale ne sera jamais
appliquée c'était peut-être la dernière
chance une évolution sans drame
en réalité derrière le pouvoir politique
les influences quelques grands colons
sont les vrais maîtres de l'algérie
comme henri borgeaud sénateur radical
grands propriétaires terriens il règne
sur 6000 personnes qui travaillent dans
ses vignes et plantations d'agrumes de
tabac ses usines de ciment
comme encore georges blache est le roi
de l'alfa qui apportent par ses
exportations 20% ces devises à l'algérie
possède le journal d'alger
enfin laurent schiaffino d'origine
napolitaine aidé à la tête d'un empire
flottant dans chaque bateau au port de
nantes n'a membres de sa nombreuse
famille
président de la chambre de commerce et
possède lui aussi un journal dépêche
quotidienne
[Musique]
tous les européens ne sont évidemment
pas milliardaire le petit peu que
pieds-noirs prolétarisés a en général un
niveau de vie inférieur à celui des
métropolitains
[Musique]
on retrouve également une forte
disparité chez les musulmans deux
millions d'entre eux mais dp6 d'une
relative aisance les autres la majorité
souffre de la pauvreté de la misère même
une scolarisation à suffisant 16 % des
enfants de gisements seulement voir
l'école
l'explosion démographique accentue les
inégalités allongé files de chômeurs
il faudrait à tout cela beaucoup
d'imagination pour se sentir des
français à part entière
[Musique]
des grandes figures de la contestation
ces deux figures croisés et
contradictoires d'ailleurs c'est ferhat
abbas d'un côté et messali hadj et
l'autre est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est
d'un côté le le réformiste de l'autre le
révolutionnaire
où il ya du vrai là dedans disons que
l'un sait faire à tabac se faire à tabac
c'est un politicien d'un politicien de
la troisième république de la quatrième
république il a un côté d'ascq est déjà
physique à côté très rock et costume un
peu avachi la poignée de main facile etc
mais c'est un homme qui avant la guerre
voulait lui absolument la
l'assimilation et puis il s'est rendu
compte que personne
exactement elle va très vite et après la
guerre il n'en veut plus il a créé un
parti qui s'appelle l'union démocratique
pour le manifeste algérien l'udma et ils
demandent quoi lui alors lui il veut que
ses saillies doucement mais que nous
allions
en algérie vers un pays qui soit libéré
du colonialisme veut pas mettre du tout
les européens deux heures mais il veut
aller tranquillement vers l'indépendance
et c'est un homme qui fait peur aux
européens indices ont oscillé plus les
plus évolués les plus importants
politiquement parce que ils se disent
celui là il est trop polis les trop
modéré il est trop poli pour être
profondément honnête il faut s'en méfier
et face à ça il ya messali hadj à l'envi
de ses adjoints n'ont pas du tout pas du
tout messali hadj ils emballent les
foules musulmanes mais les européens eux
connaissent très peu et puis le méprise
un petit peu d'abord messali hadj
pratiquement il est toujours en prison
c'est un homme qui est qui est un ancien
communiste il est passé dans les années
30 par ce creuset formidable de la
politique qu'on retrouve dans tous les
pays et que ce français qui a été le
creuset de renault il a travaillé comme
manoeuvre chez renault il a appris
exactement et puis il a été un petit peu
plus loin quand même dans ces études si
j'ose dire puisque on retrouve sa trace
on retrouve sa trace dans différents
endroits on le retrouve à bruxelles on
retrouve au caire on retrouve à moscou
où il s'est fait exactement liés disons
qu'il est ni agitateurs me miss un homme
parce que on se déplacer des foules
entières qui font entendre audience
énorme audience est d'ailleurs alors lui
il va pas avec le dos de la cuillère il
se fait ils se baptisent el saïd
l'unique et lui alors oui vraiment il
veut l'indépendance dès 1937 il a créé
son parti qui le parti populaire
algérien il a fait peur à ce moment là
on a supprimé on a interdit le parti et
depuis il est clandestin et alors là
c'est à ce moment là en 1946 il crée un
parti qui va être la couverture du ppa
qui est clandestin et ce parti ça va
être le mtld dont on a beaucoup parlé ça
veut dire le mouvement pour le triomphe
des libertés démocratiques par avoir
démocrate voilà c'est le paravent d'une
pratique et ça va être un triomphe
d'ailleurs pour messali hadj aux
élections municipales de 1947 et là on
va en parler parce que va commencer une
deuxième cause de la guerre d'algérie
c'est que il ya bien des élections des
élections démocratiques
mais à chaque fois qu'est ce qui se
passe eh bien on voit des élections avec
des urnes qui sont déjà remplies je veux
pas dire à ras bord mais pas loin de
bulletins pré fall à ce moment là le
fameux statut de 40 celles qui marquent
et des progrès timide mais réel en fait
n'est jamais appliquée elle l'a jamais
appliquée se pose c'est pas difficile
d'ailleurs parce que on revient à ces
grands groupes de pression chez ces gros
colon
qui font dix ans qu'on pourrait appeler
de l'obstruction colonialiste à
l'assemblée algérienne donc il suffit de
tenir la majorité pour que ce statut
soit jamais appliquée et c'est très
exactement ce qui va se passer les
élections l'assemblée algérienne de 48
on a vu le sur les images de
commentaires qui annonce la défaite des
partis des partis nationalistes
évidemment ces élections vers laon
conduire vraiment que tout est rentré
sur nadia il ya des bons candidats a
engagé les chiffres ici des bons
candidats qui sont élus à 98 99 cents et
même sans 2% des voix et comment vous
expliquer cette sorte de d'incapacité de
la métropole de la france de réformer
alors qu' un mouvement de général de à
ce moment-là de décolonisation pourquoi
il ya une telle cécité sur ce qui se
passe en algérie parce qu'on ne veut pas
le voir parce qu'on est encore sous le
régime des partis il faudra attendre la
cinquième république et 1958 parce que
les gouvernements pour vous dire entre
1945 et le 13 mai 1958 avec l'arrivée de
de gaulle il y aura 16 gouvernement vous
rendez compte un gouvernement qu'est ce
que ça fait ça fait six mois on a perdu
complètement l'habitude on ne s'en
souvient plus moi je me souviens encore
et il ya beaucoup de français qui s'en
souviennent encore à cette époque-là bon
gouvernement absolument besoin d'avoir
une majorité et cette majorité il la
trouve chez des gens comme rené meyer
chez ces groupes de pression chez ces
gros colon chez ses élus
[Musique]
la chute de dien bien phu
7954 provoque l'arrivée au pouvoir de
pierre mendès france
dans le gouvernement qu'il présente au
président coty françois mitterrand
reçoit le portefeuille de l'intérieur
qui comprend l'algérie
à peine pierre mendès france at il signé
les accords de genève et enfin à la
guerre d'indochine qu'il est confronté
aux troubles en afrique du nord le maroc
est en ébullition et la tunisie s'agite
mais le 31 juillet mendès france et à
carthage il fait connaître aux baies et
proposition française qui tente à
accorder au peuple tunisien sur
l'autonomie interne
l'algérie en cette année 54 semble se
tenir à l'écart de cette agitation mais
le ministre de l'intérieur est décidée
amorcé les évolutions nécessaires pierre
nicolaï directeur de cabinet de françois
mitterrand est chargé de prendre des
contacts
ce qui m'a été dit et redit à plusieurs
reprises à chaque fois que j'allais en
algérie avant c'était que l'algérie ne
connaissait pas de problèmes politiques
uniquement des problèmes économiques ce
qui signifiait donnez nous de l'argent
et laissez nous gouverner
c'était ça la beauce fait bon effet dans
ce climat là que j'ai cherché encore
encore d'accord bien entendu avec
françois mitterrand a essayé de faire
évoluer l'algérie une évolution qu'il
pourrait s'être totalement inéluctable
et le thème général de nos réflexions
c'était encore très très loin de ce qui
est arrivé par la suite mais enfin le
thème était à voir vous trouvez dans le
monde musulman une élite qui pourrait
un beau jour vous voulez plus vite
possible arrivée à prendre des
responsabilités
c'est à dire avoir des interlocuteurs
alors que jusqu alors les interlocuteurs
du mouvement général d'alger c'était des
personnages qui était en quête davantage
ou de décoration c'était bien il
comptait pas politiquement
il est déjà bien tard les interlocuteurs
valables on essaie de tirer les
sonnettes d'autres dans l'ombre se
prépare à l'action
là il faudrait revenir très rapidement
et dire qu'à l'intérieur du mtld il ya
un mouvement qui s'est formée qui
s'appelle l'organisation spéciale cette
organisation spéciale elle s'est faite
parce que une partie des durs du mtld on
est des activistes en ont eu assez de
voir toutes ces élections truquées dont
nous avons parlé et ils ont décidé de
créer un organisme qu'ils soient
spécialisés dans la révolution c'est ce
qu'on appelle l' os organisation
spéciale dans cette es en 1950 on peut
dire que cette organisation a été
démantelé mais en définitive elle a
politisé des hommes parmi lesquels on va
retrouver les fils de la toussaint ou
d'autres comme ali mahsas ben bella et
d'autre et eux
ont été soit fait prisonnier et se sont
évadés soit on réussit à échapper à la
police mais c'est à partir d'eux que va
vraiment se crée la révolution va se
faire le crua qui s'appelle qui est le
comité révolutionnaire d'unité et
d'action qui est l'ancêtre du fln
au printemps 2009 154 le mtld le parti
de messali hadj traverse une grave crise
interne
les militants se déchirent entre fidèles
du vieux prophète et partisans de son
ancien lieutenant lahouel
lassé de ces querelles intestines un
petit groupe de militants convaincus de
la nécessité de la lutte armée décide de
créer un instrument de l'insurrection
ont cru à ses fondateurs sont les chefs
historiques et fils de la toussaint et
sont tous recherchés près police rabah
bitat 28 ans mostefa ben boulaïd 37 ans
mourad didouche 32 ans mohamed boudiaf
35 ans belkacem krim 32 ans larbi ben
m'hidi 29 ans ces hommes jeunes ont
décidé de changer le cours de l'histoire
il court hier c'est ici dans ce café au
carrefour de l'odéon que toute cette
histoire a commencé on peut dire et bien
en partie oui parce que ya là deux fils
de la toussaint qui vont rencontrer un
troisième homme ses deux fils de la
toussaint sont mohamed boudiaf didouche
mourad et qui viennent rencontrer un
garçon qui s'appelle ali mahsas et
alluma saas
représentent une partie du mtld en
france
c'est au printemps 1954 c'est ici que
halima sas va avoir comme mission de
faire en sorte que la population
musulmane de france qui est fort
nombreuse s'intéresse
à la révolution s'intéresse aux mtv
moment-là boudia pas décidé de créer le
crua le comité a bûché dans des idées
d'actions alors mohamed boudiaf il a 35
ans c'est un constantinois un homme qui
est cultivé c'est pas du tout un petit
berger de du bled c'est un ancien
militaire il est adjudant il a fait la
guerre il à la médaille militaire il à
la croix de guerre il a été condamné en
l'autre garçon qui est beaucoup plus
jeune didouche-mourad il a 27 ans lui
c'est un algérois il est de familles
aisées ses parents et est aisé il a été
arrêté en 50 il s'est évadé et lui aussi
est un clandestin alors il ya d'autres
garçons qui viennent se greffer
là-dessus qu'ils sont tous des anciens
os il ya rabah bitat qui à 28 ans qui
est inconstante et noir qui aiguille
alors d'une famille tout à fait
misérable condamné à mort en 50
clandestins et qu'elle joue et comment
sont tous des bons pedigree ouais ils
sont tous vraiment des mails et des
militants qui sont prêts à mettre leur
peau d'où leur idée ça nombre d'entre
eux vont le faire puisqu'il aura pas
tellement de survivants des fils de la
toussaint il ya un autre homme qui est
très important qui est mustapha ben
boulaïd ben boulaïd et c'est un cétacé
algérien dit peu curieux et qui n'ont
rien à voir avec les arabes d'algérie
qui n'ont rien à voir avec
seal si ce n'est un lointain cousinage
avec les kabyles qui sont ceux qu'on
appelle les chaouia et chaouia des aurès
et là c'est ce sont des gens qui de
tradition il ya une formidable tron
tradition des bandits d'honneur comme
comme on l'a eu encore ce jusque là
troisième république donc lui c'est un
homme tout à fait décider alors le
dernier maintenance et krim belkacem
c'est l'apport de cabine krim belkacem
c'est un homme qui a 32 ans et un kabyle
c'est un fils de caïds alors là caïd je
rappelle rapidement ce que c'est c'est
dans ces communes du bled c'est il est à
la fois juge administrateurs c'est lui
qui dirige un petit peu la police et
krim belkacem lui alors il s'est
véritablement
dressé mais de toutes les fibres de son
être contre cette politique de désir ne
truque et kick ass est absolument tout
espoir aux gens qui comme lui voulait
faire quelque chose avec leur pays ils
voulaient voir leur pays allait vers
l'indépendance mais si l'on ne parle et
qui font figure sur cette photo
historique a été prise avant
l'insurrection il faut ajouter trois
autres noms qui sont en terrain connu
aujourd'hui son benbella aït ahmed et
voilà qu'il quittait alors mohamed
khider c'est un homme lui qui est tout à
fait comme ferhat abbas il a été député
élu député d'alger depuis 1946 il s'est
enfui à l'expiration de son mandat et
c'est un homme qui représente le mt lt
au caire ahmed benbella lui aussi ses
arts voilà encore un qui est adjudant
médaille militaire croix derrière ses
terres à cassino qui c'est qui a
combattu véritablement comme comme à
lyon et qui en 1950 était un des
responsables de l' os l'organisation
spéciale qui a été arrêté qui s'était
évadé en 1952 et qui a été le chef de l'
os de même que hocine aït ahmed qui est
le troisième qui lui est kabyle qui est
un fils de caïds un homme qui est de
loin de siaulai des neuf l'édifice de la
toussaint et les trois du caire qui est
de loin le plus lettré et certainement
le plus rhdp anisé et disons le mot
certainement le plus intelligent pour la
petite histoire que oui c'est un homme
dont on parle aujourd'hui face au fils
c'est l'homme du parti socialiste kabyle
disons que c'est l'homme en tête dans
cette kabylie qui en ce moment est en
train de se lever on le voit dans les
colonnes des journaux alors ces trois là
ok il représente le mtld auprès de la
ligue arabe mais la ligue arabe et aux
prêts des lits à tous tous ces partis
pas seulement algérien hassen c'est bien
de tout le monde arabe dans tout ce qui
bouge alors disons qu'il ya surtout
beaucoup de palabres et pas grand-chose
grand chose d'autre il ya une chose qui
est beaucoup plus importante c'est que
ben bella lui c'est lié avec gamal abdel
nasser qui est le patron de fo
le tout récent patron de l'egypte et
surtout avec fatiha lisible qui est le
chef des services spéciaux de nasser et
fathi el dib qui disent on est copain
avec ben bella lui dit d'accord on vous
aidera il faut vous montriez ce que vous
voulez faire il faut que vous commenciez
vous même la révolution et que vous
restiez pas dans votre coin comme ça a
continué à palabrer alors il faut que
vous fassiez vos preuves
depuis le printemps 1954 mais si chef du
crua se rencontrent régulièrement dans
les lieux secrets la casbah d'alger et
recrutent des chefs de commandos chargés
à leur tour de trouver des hommes qui
ignore l'identité des six chefs le 3
juin les fils de la conscience
répartissent les zones et prendrons plus
tard le nom de wilaya abengourou l'ied
la zone de l'aurès hammourabi louche la
zone 2 du nord pensons qu'une loi à
belkacem krim la zone 3 de kabylie en
habitat de la zone 4 de l'algérois larbi
ben m'hidi la zone 5 2 lors année
mohamed boudia pays du président du crua
d'assurer la coordination et la liaison
avec les représentants du caire
le 25 juillet en l'absence de belkacem
krim et cinq chefs réunissent leurs 17 y
attenant au clos salembier sur les
hauteurs d'alger lors de cette réunion
historique l'époque deux se prononce
pour le déclenchement des six mois la
lutte armée jusqu'à l'indépendance à
l'automne après avoir déterminé un
certain nombre d'objectifs pour le jour
de la résurrection une charge de leur
zone de fabriquer les beaux ils ignorent
que depuis quelques temps déjà ils sont
sous la surveillance de jambes aux joues
directeur de la sûreté à alger et que
l'artificier qu'ils ont choisie est un
indicateur
[Musique]
un nommé commissaire manipuler un
informateur qui était dans le groupe dit
de la casbah et un jour il est arrivé en
nous disant disant commissaire on me
demande maintenant de
préparer des bombes avec des explosifs
alors le commissaire m'a dit qu'est ce
que je dis à l'informateur et j'ai dit à
ce commissaire vous avez une femme
pharmacienne demandez lui s'il ya un
produit qui pourrait faire du bruit mais
pas de mal et c'est à ce moment là
qu'elle a dit et qu'elle nous a fait
dire qu'il fallait employer du chlorate
de potasse on a donné ce tuyau si je
puis dire au un autre informateur qui a
fabriqué un sert d'une certaine centaine
je crois de bombes comme ça avec
déplorable de potasse si confiant la cje
comprend bien les bombes d'alger ont été
préparés selon les indications
exactement j'ai même sorti deux mille
francs de mon portefeuille pour acheter
du crack de potasse avait payé
à la mi octobre le ministre l'intérieur
françois mitterrand bien se rendre
compte sur place des dégâts causés par
le violent tremblement terre caravage et
orléans ville le 9 septembre les loin de
se douter qu une résurrection est
imminente d'autant que les autorités
locales lui tiennent des propos
rassurants
[Musique]
le 18 octobre le remet la légion
d'honneur à raymond latière président de
l'assemblée algérienne et lapierre a
remercié en prononçant cette phrase
monsieur le ministre
n'écoutez pas la voix des sirènes qui
vous disent que l'algérie risquerait
d'être contaminé par ses voisins
je peux vous dire aujourd'hui monsieur
le ministre que l'algérie est calme et
qu'elle le restera
à la fin du voyage ministériel vaujour
qui semble être un des seuls à s'alarmer
prévient nicolaï
bonjour m'a pris à part l'aérodrome et
m'a expliqué que à ses yeux c'était pour
les premiers jours de novembre
il avait
décelé
des complots d'un an petit nombre de
l'algérien qui se préparait à faire un
coup et là mais peut-être un petit
nombre est allé à ce moment là il m'a
dit mais ce que je voudrais savoir c'est
que quelle option choisissez vous
entretenez d'une solution la première
qui consiste à mettre la main dessus
tout de suite nous pouvons le faire nous
les connaissons mais au risque de
laisser filer des tas d'autres que nous
ne connaissons pas
deuxième option attendre qu'il se
manifeste et façon à pouvoir mettre la
main sur un nombre plus considérable de
gens qui seraient compromis dans la même
entreprise alors c'est une réponse que
je lui ai pas donné tout de suite parce
que je voulais en parler à françois
mitterrand je lui en ai parlé dans
l'avion libé tête non plus avec une
crème reparti il m'a dit qu'il allait
réfléchir à cette question de gestion
assez hésitant sur la solution
am l'avion ministre à qu'il décollait
que vos jours reçoit un rapport
alarmiste des renseignements généraux ce
rapport prévoit le début de
l'insurrection dans un avenir très
proche bonjour décide aussitôt de
prévenir paris
j'ai immédiatement
fait venir la secrétaire et je lui ai
dicté la page que le gouverneur général
a signé
et qui se terminer par cette phrase
désormais sommes nous à la veille de
d'un certain de d'incident ou
d'attentats en algérie
il est impossible de l'affirmer d'une
façon absolue mais on peut vraiment le
redouté
ça me paraissait assez clair pour ceux
qui allaient le recevoir
il s'est passé le dimanche
le lundi
je n'avais toujours rien aucune nouvelle
on fait un coup de téléphone mais
n'avait eu aucune réponse leucan écho du
côté du cabinet du ministre du ministre
le 2 novembre j'ai reçu une lettre le 2
novembre
à en me disant vous pouvez les coffrets
pas besoin de vous dire que
effectivement
j'étais tout disposé à le faire déjà et
pour cause dès le 10 octobre les six
fils de la toussaint les fixer la date
de l'insurrection au 1er novembre à zéro
heure date qui ne devait révéler alors
commando maintenue sous pression que six
heures auparavant le nom du crua avait
été abandonnée pour celui de fln front
de libération nationale pour la branche
armée était à l aile armée de libération
nationale
le 24 octobre des six tiennent une
dernière réunion à alger et en profite
pour faire la photo historique
[Musique]
avec 400 armes essentiellement des
fusils de chasse des bombes artisanales
et moins d'un millier d'hommes et ne
doute pas un instant de l'avenir
vos jours sans que les événements
s'accélèrent comme on lui signale la
présence de 300 tenaga dans les aurès il
provoque une réunion à constantine avec
les responsables politiques et
militaires de la région
[Musique]
deux colonels blanche qui commandait le
secteur manille au monsieur le préfet
tout ça c'est des histoires
on est en train d'affabuler et il a eu
cette phrase superbe il m'a dit moi je
me balade tous les jours même la nuit
quelques fois dans les aurès jamais je
n'ai vu dans les phares de majipoor
fellaghas
le l'administrateur daris m'a dit je
confirme entièrement ce qu'a dit le le
colonel blanche
s'il y avait vraiment des insoumis dans
les aurès je le saurai et personne n'y a
cru
le compte à rebours a commencé mais
personne ne le sait hormis une poignée
d'hommes résolu
il faut courir quand on écoute jean
vaujour on se rend compte qu'il était
extrêmement bien informé qu'il a prévenu
les autorités et finalement il ya très
peu de réaction finalement oui encore
une fois paris et comment vous expliquez
ça on envoie un rapport qui est
extrêmement alarmistes qui annonce qu'il
va y avoir des choses très très sérieuse
des attentats il a parle de cette
histoire de bon dans la casbah personnes
se précipitent pourquoi en direct des
mesures ce fameux rappeur c'est le
rapport du 23 octobre à françois
mitterrand qui est ministre de
l'intérieur et qui vient de venir en
algérie donc le rapport qu'est-ce qu'il
dit le mouvement couvre toute l'algérie
mais
répondant de toute façon c'est quelque
chose qui est venu de l'étranger c'est
ben bella qui
synchronise tout ça du caire le caire
agit sur les populations et puis surtout
le rapport tout bêtement il se perd à
paris et ce père pourquoi parce que il
ya cette sacro-sainte politique du
parapluie les attachés de cabinet les
chefs de cabinet aux adhérents va pas
déranger le ministre mais non on n'y
croit pas et pourquoi il ya ce vos
joueurs ben bien sûr il est le patron
c'était oui mais quand même on croit
ceux des matières on croit les tout ce
qu'ils disent et y compris les
militaires n'ont depuis 1945 il y a eu
ses tifs il y a eu la répression il ya
eu le coup de bâton on les tient bien
ils ne vont pas bouger après tout ce
n'est qu'un flic en même temps un grand
flic mais c'est un flic exactement
exactement et il n'a pas eu grand lille
n'a pas la considération alors que c'est
véritablement un très haut fonctionnaire
et un homme qui connaît formidablement
bien son affaire et bien
il n'a pas l'oreille du ministre alors
juste à la veille du 1er novembre
qu'elle le crua ça représente quoi
t'est-ce quelles sont les forces des ces
types qui se lancent ces hommes qui se
lancent dans cette dans cette aventure
depuis l' os ils ont recruté selon la
méthode pyramidale c'est à dire qu'il en
a un qui connaît trois copains les trois
copains recrute 3 autres et personne ne
se connaît entre ya juste le l'homme du
départ le suivant et après trois aux
dacquois zone où tout est cloisonné bon
alors qu'est ce qu'il y à il y a deux
forces principales il ya les 450 hommes
des kabyles parce que krim belkacem et
le sergent ou à branne aussi un homme
qui vient de de l'armée française et qui
a très bien combattu pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale eh bien ils ont
créé des groupes des groupes armés est
depuis longtemps parce qu'il faut pas
oublier que au 1er novembre 1954 krim
belkacem lui tient le mât qui depuis
déjà sept ans pour des tas de raisons je
peux pas vous raconter ici ce serait
beaucoup trop long mais lui sait il
s'est vraiment mis hors la loi
lanceur l'algérie alors la 450 hommes
chez lui en kabylie il ya les hommes de
ben boulaïd ans et aurait ce dont je
vous ai parlé c'est aux rays sauvages
alors là il ya 400 hommes de très
politisé réunis en cellule en groupe
d'action et la chose encore plus
importante c'est que ben boulaïd lui
dispose d'une réserve d'armes de caches
d'armes qui datent de l'époque de l'eau
sdd récupération pendant la guerre etc
c'est la plus importante de l'algérie
enfin c'est pas quelque chose d'énorme
et puis alors alger il n'y a pas
grand-chose à alger il ya rabah bitat tu
qui a créé ces
ateliers de fabrication de fabrication
de bombes dont jean vaujour a eu
connaissance et a eu un des exemplaires
bon mais il n'y a pas énormément de
choses il ya tout de même quelque chose
quelque a pu obtenir boudiaf au caire
c'est que benbella qui était le patron
de l'ol lui a donné des caches
relativement importante avec quelques
les mitraillettes destin à l'époque dont
ils ont en gros au 1er novembre 54 ce
qu'ils vont déclencher la toussaint
rouge comme on l'a dit d'une façon un
petit peu un petit peu outré c'est à peu
près 1000 hommes mais avec vraiment quoi
400 armes 500 armes grand maximum on
peut dire qu'il ya pas d'armes il n'y a
pas d'argent et surtout il n'y a pas de
soutien populaire parce que parce que le
peuple ne les connais pas encore mais il
ya la volonté des six fils de la
toussaint et puis la volonté des trois
du caire et voilà il fait ils vont
mettre le feu aux poudres en faisant dix
ont
éclaté un gros pétard et comme le disait
le président mao la plaine était sèche
donc ça bien flamber
dimanche 31 octobre l'algérie française
vit ses derniers instants de quiétude
dans l'eau les rebelles s'apprêtent à
passer à l'action
[Musique]
résurrection démarre prématurément à
23h45 dans la région de boufarik
abraham et second de belkacem krim
attaque à cazères six fusils 4
mitraillettes sont raflés au poste
gardent la coopérative d'agrumes est
incendiée ainsi que l' usine de papier
de ma bague
la même heure rabah bitat tu attaques
sans succès la caserne de blida et se
retirant les 103 morts
[Musique]
vers 00h30 de ferme soit attaqué entre
coulisses et bosquets et un européen et
tué devant la gendarmerie de cassaigne
à zéro heure 45 des bouts mais qu'as tu
à alger l usine à gaz pétrole maury à la
radio
à cette heure-là mais aures n'ont pas
encore bougé le jeune sous préfet une
jean d'aulps langues en poste depuis 18
mois qu'a su nouer des liens avec la
population
ryan batna après avoir dîné à
constantine avec son ami le préfet
dupuch
j'arrive à
la sous-préfecture de batna qui se
trouvait dans une grande place il était
à peu près une heure quinze
je dois la vie à sept heures parce que
derrière la murette à 8 mètres de moi il
y avait à lakhdar à la tête d'un
commando de six personnes qui avaient
mission de me tuer
mais qui ne vais me tuer qu'à 3 heures
du matin au moment de la taxe
généralisée sur ben
à jacques n'a pas hésité paraît-il
pendant quelque temps et finalement
soucieux de d'observer la discipline
il ne m'a pas tiré j'ai pu pénétrer
ainsi dans la sous-préfecture de batna
et je commençais à me déshabiller pour
voulu donner le détail
lorsque retentit
le téléphone est ce qu'au téléphone est
très important c'est celui de priol le
commissaire central de biskra qui
ensuite été chef de cabinet challenge
revenus et prix yonne m'a téléphoné il
était à peu près deux heures en me
disant
il vient d'y avoir de gros incidents à
biskra ont attaqué la commune mixte on a
attaqué le centrales électriques il ya
des blessés je tiens tout de suite avoue
prennent et
j'ai raccroché aussi tout est là je dois
dire que j'ai hésité quelques secondes
parce que où j'étais un bon petit
fonctionnaire tranquille et paisible et
je me couvrait je téléphonais à dupuch
puis au gouvernement général et puis
j'ai décidé que il fallait agir
immédiatement sur place que s'il y avait
quelque chose à biskra il y avait
quelque chose à batna et était venu tout
de suite à bourgeois bourgeois était le
capitaine car mobile comme très
remarquée
et je vais des bourgeois état d' alerte
tout le monde prêt à intervenir
soyez prêt il ya peut-être des rebelles
en ville il ya m'apprendre mon
explication mais il a déclenché la
sirène les lumières se sont allumées et
les gardes mobiles ont sorti les
automitrailleuses près intervenait ce
qui fait qu'en quelques minutes
batna à 2 heures du matin s'est éveillée
et les sept ou huit commandos qui
étaient prêts à attaquer batna a tué
surtout les militaires car il avait lors
de ménager des suivez moi j'étais
considéré quand ils étaient tous les
mangeant du commando et surtout le ben
boulaïd sont rendus compte que on
connait c'est quelque chose que leur
présence était sans doute connu et il a
fait partie la fameuse fusée rouge qui a
indiqué rob lee immédiate au lieu de
faire partir la fusée bleue qui
déclenchait la taxe généralisée sur
matin
voilà très rapidement n'y a pas eu de
frais affrontements n'y a pas eu la
preuve y a pas eu d'affrontement si ce
n'est qu' on a tiré sur le chef d'état
major et que les deux petites sentinelle
qui se trouve et devant la caserne ont
été assassinés sans pouvoir se défendre
car comble de bêtise il était de garde
il avait un fusil mais les cartouches
étaient enveloppés dans une enveloppe de
toile il n'avait pas le droit de s'en
sortir ils ont été abattus sans pouvoir
se détend
les autres village des aurès ne sont pas
épargnés à khenchela le lieutenant
d'arnaud commandant la place et un
soldat sans tuer à risque outre youtube
soit à qu'à leur tour est coupé du monde
[Musique]
à 7 heures du matin le car qui assure la
liaison biskra harris est stoppé dans
les gorges du coût des nominés
passagers doivent descendre kite sadok
l'instituteur monroe et sa femme sont
abattu d'une rafale c'est el malah
monroe survivra
dans le constantinois les gendarmeries
décompte des semaines du crew
saint-charles et suit les coups de feu
[Musique]
en kabylie et sabotages détruisent des
lignes téléphoniques les incendies
ravagent des poux de liège et de tabac
des casernes de gendarmerie sont
attaqués deux gardes champêtres ont tué
au total on dénombre huit morts des
dizaines d'attentats revendiqués par des
petits groupes qui se réclament du fln
ce qui est important c'est que on se
rend compte que ces petits groupes dont
on sait on se doute qu'ils sont pas très
importants ils sont déterminés ils vont
contre la représentation de ce qu'est le
fait colonial les casernes les
commissariats de police la commune mixte
reine celle à la caserne un lieutenant
qui est abattu autre chose on l'ordre
était surtout de ne pas toucher aux
européens mai d'abattre bien sûr des
soldats français voilà et puis à 7
heures du matin c'est ce que la
métropole retiendra il ya ce petit quart
qui prend la route biskra harris et qui
dans les gorges de tyrannie mines est
attaqué et ça ça va faire vraiment
l'effet du bombe psychologique au total
combien une trentaine quarantaine de
d'incidents recensés sur l'ensemble du
territoire absolument c'est c'est
véritablement pas grand-chose la chose
qui est la plus importante c'est que il
y à quelque part une tête qui a décidé
que tel jour à telle heure aux quatre
coins de l'algérie et de l'est à l'ouest
on pouvait montrer que le peuple se
révolte est le peuple c'est beaucoup
dire c'est une poignée d'hommes mais une
poignée d'hommes qui sont dirigés à une
soulèvement même sort alors est ce qu'on
nous a dit est ce que c'est une
insurrection est ce que c'est un
soulèvement une insurrection non dans le
sens soulèvement visant à renverser le
pouvoir ce pouvoir établi et qui est
honni mais oui dans le sens général de
l'insurrection égale révolte c'est la
révolte d'une poignée d'hommes et non
une insurrection populaire ela va être
tout le problème c'est pour cette
poignée d'hommes qui sont tous issus de
l'organisation spéciale il va falloir
ramener cette population à la révolution
et ça ça n'a pas être facile et ils vont
employer les moyens les plus les plus
dures et les plus atroces et la suite de
la guerre donc on peut dire sur le 1er
novembre sur le plan militaire avec des
guillemets semi échec sur le plan
politique retentissement énorme oui et
puis surtout qu'il ya une autre chose
c'est que radio le caire dans la matinée
annonce avec une précision que
n'ont pas pu le savoir par la radio et
parfois que ce soit donc eu le caire
savez avec précision les attentats de
toute cette nuit et là c'est une
victoire psychologique
énorme et c'est une grave erreur des
politiciens français que de dire parce
que ça les arrange il y à là dessous la
main de l'étranger quand on est grand le
complot de l'étranger c'est tellement
facile
[Musique]
on n'a pas eu l'impression que s'il
voulait que c'était une insurrection on
a cru que c'était
un trouble grave à trouve grave à
l'ordre public aussi bien j'ai qu'à
constantine que moi batman dans les
premiers jours je ne me suis pas rendu
compte immédiatement de la gravité de la
situation et j'ai cru qu'on allait nous
mépriser ce n'est quand on a arrêté les
premières personnes que on s'est rendu
compte de l'existence réelle d'un cru à
de toute une métastase
insurrectionnel sur l'ensemble de
l'algérie et qu'il faudrait beaucoup de
temps pour la faire disparaître
gilles géri et des obsèques solennelles
aux victimes de la vague d'attentats et
dans la nuit du 1er novembre a déferlé
sur divers points du territoire au cours
d'une trentaine d' attaque sept
personnes avaient trouvé la mort
à grand peine que l'on réussit à évacuer
madame monroe une jeune institutrice
grièvement blessés a appris aux côtés de
son mari animée
pour répondre à ce plan d'incitation
concertée des renforts des dépôts totaux
dépêchés vers les principaux points
névralgiques
à bord d'un hélicoptère l'envoyé du
ministre de l'intérieur survolé la
région de lorraine principal foyer de
l'habitation la planète difficulté que
j'ai eue c'est que j'ai constaté que les
hauts personnages de l'armée n'y croyais
pas ils n'ont pas pris ça au sérieux
sur place et à paris quand je suis
arrivé à alger en disant je le mardi 2
au soir j'ai une réunion avec léonard et
puis les rôles sérieux et s'est dit au
général derrière voici ce que j'ai
obtenu comme renfort renforts de troupes
il m'a à peu près dit que ça lui seul
fanni servait à rien que c'était
absolument pas important et brusquement
le lendemain ou le surlendemain je me
rappelle plus exactement alors que je
j'étais dans ma chambre vous palais
d'été je reçois goûter les foies daniel
darc qui me dire
je le souhaite pouvoir le plus vite
possible parce que le général serrières
me demande me dit qu'il va lui falloir
deux divisions pour reconquérir l'aurès
je garde cette phrase présente à
l'esprit depuis ce moment-là j'ai hurlé
de fureur pourquoi de divisions alors
que la veille on me disait qu'on a
besoin de rien et reconquérir le rsa
signifier qu'on l'avait abandonnée
à paris pierre mendès france affirme
l'algérie c'est la france on ne transige
pas quand il s'agit de défendre
l'intégrité de la république
françois mitterrand est sur la même
longueur d'onde en s'attaquant à nos
compatriotes algériens les meurtriers et
les émeutiers ont dressé contre la force
française
cette force défendra la justice en
maintenant l'unité nationale en
protégeant ceux qui travaillent et ceux
qui peinent en rétablissant la paix
cilic appuyé sur la volonté de concorde
de progrès de l'immense majorité du
peuple elle interdira aux agitateurs le
plus souvent recrutés à l'étranger la
poursuite d'une oeuvre de destruction
si les meneurs ont voulu alerter
l'opinion internationale
à la veille d'une session des nations
unies ils ont eu tort
l'algérie c'est la france et la france
ne reconnaîtra pas chez elle d'autres
autorités que la sienne
à la fin du mois de novembre
françois mitterrand retourne en algérie
en particulier dans les aurès
[Applaudissements]
sommes donc au milieu du troisième jour
ce trop bref voyage à travers la région
qui a le plus souffert
la tentative
insurrectionnelle en fit
cependant il semble bien qu'à travers
toute l'algérie est spécifiquement dans
ces lieux en 10 réceptions de vitrages
qu'elle cela de batna on évolue lever lé
peuple contre celui qu'on appelait
l'étranger où l'occupant le français la
population n'a pas compris ce langage
les rennais française elle n'a donc pas
suivi il n'a pas obéi au mot d'ordre de
ci de là et l'a évité
mère dans peu d'endroits nous leur avons
donc fallu manière collective nous nous
éviterons tout ce qui pourrait
apparaître comme une sorte d'étape
guerre nous ne voulons pas mais douch
attirons une manière implacable
sans autre souci que celui de la justice
et à la circonstance la justice exige la
rigueur des responsables et tous ceux
qui seront surpris
agissant d'une façon évidente par les
moyens des armes contre eux entre
l'ordre et doit savoir que le risque
pour une immense dans leur vie dans leur
bien et si nous le regrettons puisque ce
sont nos concitoyens ils sont soumis
comme tous criminels à la loi la loi
sera appliquée
trong a donné des consignes de
bertinghen
extrêmement strictes il voulait que
l'ordre soit rétabli
dans les aurès d'une manière légale bien
entendu mais sans aucune tablette
comme la guerre d'algérie
si tu son point de départ que ce soit
une exacte enfin c'est sensationnel
au 1er novembre
1954 et que j'ai dû miser un intérieur
bien entendu on s'est tourné vers moi
j'ai très bien accepté cette
responsabilité mais que c'est elle me
revenait non pas la responsabilité de la
guerre mais la responsabilité de prendre
les mesures qu'ils contenaient pour
faire face à cette situation qui de nos
positions et d'une
hostilité larvée il s'est signalé de
temps à autre par des incidents ça va
être un coup des incidents coordonner le
début du jeûne à boeing était en effet
bien que j'ai donc bien là tu bien les
censures et moi nous sommes très bien
entendus et je dois dire que une fois
passée cette nuit de la toussaint uni ou
sept morts sept morts cinq dans le
département du côté des aurès ses
diamants les parlements de constantine
et de bandes département d'alger et
l'autre dans le département de roue
puisque c'étaient des départements
entre ce moment là elle départ d'une
mêlée sens et il n'y a pas eu de
ici et là des incidents que ça pouvait
être considérée comme grave mais il n'y
a pas eu d'attentât je surveille guerre
d'algérie un important engagement a eu
lieu dans les environs de tours ou unité
parachutiste a pénétré dans le village
d'accueil en flammes
les hors la loi ont laissé quelques
morts et plusieurs blessés
ratissage dans la montagne
interrogatoires des suspects
vérification d'identité les habitants
appellent aux populations à se réfugier
dans les secteurs de sécurité toutes ces
mesures ne manqueront pas de ramener le
calme dans l'oreille
mais pierre mendès france et françois
mitterrand savent qu'elles ne résoudront
pas la question algérienne par la seule
politique du bâton au conseil des
ministres du 5 janvier françois
mitterrand présente un programme de
réformes économiques sociales et
culturelles dans l'esprit du ministre
les musulmans doivent bénéficier des
mêmes droits que les européens
étaient de ramat et parce que ce plan de
réforme elle était j'appelle ça
aujourd'hui une réformette quand on
regarde ce à la lumière des faits qui ne
s'est pas fait depuis faderne ce n'est
rien du tout mais ce que l'on mesure mal
aujourd'hui c'est la difficulté qu'on
avait même de faire une réforme est
alors c'est sûr ces projets que ma
naissance est tombé le débat sur la
politique nord africaine du gouvernement
a sonné le glas du cabinet mendès-france
y abandonne le pouvoir après huit mois
bien remplie
[Musique]
je n'ai je n'ai rien à dire
moment nous sommes
je ne cache pas mon émotion
je ne cache pas non plus ma peine
non pour moi bien entendu
mais parce que je crois que l'entreprise
à laquelle s'était attaché le
gouvernement que je présidais était
bonne pour le pays
et que je regrette qu'elle soit
maintenant interrompu
les réactions en france du gouvernement
aussi bien de camalès france qui est
présent du conseil que françois
mitterrand commises à l'intérieur c'est
de répondre ce qui vient de passer en
algérie est grave mais l'algérie c'est
la france il n'y a pas de ces cessions
possibles donc à l'époque personne
n'envisage une seconde que ce qui va se
passer
on enclenche une guerre de huit ans
absolument pas parce que
naguère on y pense absolument pas au
conseil on prend la faire comme on le
considère la faire comme du maintien de
l'ordre
et on ne va pas regarder les causes et
la profondeur de l'insurrection par
exemple vous avez vu les titres des
journaux on arrête tous les gens qui
sont fichés au mtld non là ça rend un
service formidable au fln qui lui est
déjà en opposition avec la soul a rien à
voir absolument pas alors la politique
d'alger ça va être d'imposer à la france
cette politique qui est pas de réforme
de faire des réformes maintenant ce
serait donner une prime à la révolte et
ça on n'en veut pas dès le début il ya
deux camps même de voler dans la
politique du gouvernement madness france
a rétabli l'ordre et ça c'est le boulot
si j'ose dire il me l'intérieur et 2 on
met en place avec des réformes les deux
sont simultanés alors d'abord le
maintien d'ordre dans votre bouquin vous
dit que quand même le mieux à
l'intérieur françois mitterrand était
partisan du maintien de l'ordre c'est
musclé oui absolument mais s'est il fait
il fait son travail de ministre de
l'intérieur de l'époque mais vous avez
en face ces militaires qui disaient et
la veille encore tout va bien de notre
foi alors le général shir yole
commandante en chef qu'on appelle bavard
parce que c'est un homme un petit peu
fort kylie qui va essayer de passer les
aurès au peigne fin vous avez vu la
configuration des aurès passer ça au
peigne fin c'est vraiment de la folie
douce alors on va quand même pas assez
dans les villages et dans les villages
qu'est ce qui se passe des exactions
cette population qui n'est pas pour ce
mouvement au départ il va se retrouver
prise entre l'arbre et les corses et ça
c'est inquiétant mais elle basculera pas
se passer tout de suite mais
basculera de la même façon que la
population d'alger après la bataille
d'alger en 1956 basculera du côté du fln
parce que il ya cet engrenage attentats
répression et répression c'est un peu
plus musclée ce plan de réforme qui
essaye de mettre en place au
gouvernement mades que présente françois
mitterrand conseil des ministres début
janvier est ce qu'il est ce que c'est
trop tard est-ce que c'est complètement
chimérique qu'est-ce qu'il a eu aucune
chance de s que c'est trop tard pour les
réformes parce que la guerre est
inévitable mais les réformes il faudrait
qu'elle soit appliquée je peux pas moi
je ne fais pas partie de la tribu des
yaka et des faucons
je ne fais pas les réformes elles ne
sont pas appliquées la politique des
groupes de pression algérois et lg rien
c'est de dire pas de réforme les
réformes on verra plus tard
pas de réformes tant que l'ordre n'est
pas rétabli et c'est très exactement ce
qui se passe l'ordre établi à turin
grosso modo sauf dans les aurès mais il
ya eu des allégations pas de réforme non
absolument pas ne serait-ce que le
statut de 1947 parce que très peu de
temps avant le déclenchement du 1er
novembre 1954 pierre mendès-france a
reçu ferhat abbas avec
dans des circonstances tout à fait
entouré de secret mais qu'est ce qu'ils
demandent ferhat abbas devant d'une
seule chose pour président du conseil je
vous en supplie appliquer le statut de
1947 et ne fait plus d'élections
truquées comme celle que etc et que l'on
vient de voir alors ça ne se produira
jamais et puis ma ds france est lâché en
particulier on reprend retrouve son nom
par rené meyer l'homme qui dit toujours
nous n'accepterons jamais l'assimilation
et il les rend t il renverser et qu'est
ce qui dit et pour moi ce sera le mot de
la fin en quittant le gouvernement en
afrique du nord ou bien ce sera la
politique d'entente ou bien la politique
de répression et de force avec toutes
ces horribles conséquences c'est ce qui
s'est passé
les neuf chefs historiques ont connu un
destin tragique
mourad didouche et tué en opération en
1955 mostefa ben boulaïd saute sur un
poste émetteur piéger par les services
français en 1956
larbi benmhidi est arrêté par les hommes
de bigeard 1957 on ne le reverra jamais
où un maître khider trésorier du fln est
assassiné à madrid en 1967
el kacem crime est retrouvée étranglée
dans une chambre d'hôtel à francfort en
mohamed boudiaf président de la
république était assassiné à alger en
rabah bitat d'aujourd'hui alger ben
bella a fait une vingtaine d'années de
prison ait ahmed après la prison et
l'exil se bat aujourd'hui pour une
algérie démocratique
[Musique]
et pour terminer les livres qui nous ont
aidés à préparer cette émission pour
ceux qui veulent en savoir plus et
d'abord et avant tout le livre d'yves
courrière la guerre d'algérie l'histoire
la guerre d'algérie des fils de la
puissance assez le tome 1 donc qui
concernent directement évidemment
l'émission de ce soir paru chez fayard
il ya 25 ans et qu'on trouve aujourd'hui
chez laffont en collection bouquins et
fils de la toussaint d'yves courrière le
livre indispensable
le point de vue d'un historien algérien
mohamed harbi historien et acteurs
d'ailleurs paru chez complexe la guerre
commence en algérie le 1er novembre 1954
deux histoires très synthétique et très
bonne de la guerre d'algérie une barioz
point en point histoire histoire la
guerre d'algérie bernard droz évident le
vert excellente synthèse et celle de
benjamin stora histoire de la guerre
d'algérie paru à la découverte
enfin deux témoignages celui de hocine
aït ahmed mémoire d'un combattant
l'esprit d'indépendance
42,52 paru chez sylvie messinger il ya
quelques années hocine ait ahmed vous
l'avez vu dans l'émission c'est l'un des
side dans les pardons l'année six chefs
historiques un des six fils de la
toussaint et c'est son témoignage sur
son itinéraire de combattants l'autre
témoignage c'est celui de jean vaujour
que vous avez vu également dans
l'émission de la révolte à la révolution
au premier jour la guerre d'algérie ge
paru chez albin michel il ya quelques
années où il reprend et développe
naturellement tout ce qu'il savait sur
les préparatifs de l'insurrection enfin
un dossier préparé par la revue
l'histoire les drames de la guerre
d'algérie dossier sur la guerre
d'algérie donc dans la revue l'histoire
du mois d'octobre voilà le mois prochain
les brûleurs de l'histoire seront
consacrés à un dossier particulièrement
délicat l'épuration bonsoir
[Musique]
m
là
[Musique]
on